[Musique]
je veux porter un nouvel espoir celui
d'une nouvelle france que nous devons
reconstruire ensemble
je suis d'une trame corps je veux la
france nord car je veux la force cela
je veux un pacte de réconciliation
nationale un pacte qui apaise les colère
parce qu'on ne gouvernera plus les
français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fronde
le soin symisa personnes
puissante et coupé
dix ans respecté
puis la candidate du travail la feuille
de paye dans ma france florence jamais
si gens qui ne sont rien je serai la
présidente de tous les français
[Applaudissements]
barcella motors en reprochant à la
france un crime contre l'humanité
qu'elle n'a jamais connue
je l'accuse d'avoir patia lisez la
critique
je l'accuse de vouloir des confirme
notre histoire je l'accuse d'avoir nier
l'existence de la culture française
je serai implacable autres tous ceux qui
s'attaquent à la république
à mieux et prêcheurs de haine de l'islam
hinault ce nouveau totalitarisme il va
détruire ce que nous sommes et c'est
pour cela que nous patrons pour la
laïcité
je combats lui
hu a kiss et au delà tous ces mouvements
anti veulent déconstruire
il est temps de protéger les temps de
repenser
les dans le progrès et il est temps de
vous respecter il est temps de
réconcilier les français il est temps
d'avoir une police à l'elysée
[Musique]